hey everyone I'm hiar nakura and this is
my Google Auto wait what was it Google
what this is my Google auto complete so
the first one we're going to do is right
here this is what is Hikaru nakur IQ
this is a great question obviously uh I
don't know the answer to this one myself
I did an online fun one on stream and it
was 109 or 102 obviously that's not
accurate but nobody knows what is Hikaru
nakura net worth of course very famous
question one that I've seen many times
and the answer is not going to be 50
million for anybody who anybody at home
who's wondering what did he carar study
in college that of course the answer
would be political science I did not
actually finish but I would have uh
majored in that what is Hikaru nakura
ranking okay currently number three in
the world in classical chess and I think
number number two in Blitz something
like that what is Hikaru
nakur chess rating okay pretty similar
to the previous one that currently I
believe would be 2780 if I'm not
mistaken what is Hikaru nur's favorite
opening I don't necessarily have a
favorite opening per se but I do like
the move 1
E4 how old is hikara nakura the answer
of course would be 35 at the present
time how tall is he Caron aquara um and
this one it's generally 5 5' 72 in I
don't know what that is in European
standards but it's something decent at
least how much does he Cura
make obviously I I do quite well as a
content creator so I think that's that's
all that people really need to know how
to pronounce Hikaru nak now even myself
when I pronounce my name it's definitely
more Americanized versus Japanese
certainly if I was pronouncing it
correctly it would be more like Hikaru
as opposed to Hikaru but I've spent so
much of my life here in America that
that's just how I pronounce and everyone
does the same thing how smart is hikaro
nakun now this of course similar to the
IQ question before I wonder what that
what would actually pop on Google and
people type that in but it probably
would be pretty similar to the IQ uh
suggestions as well who is hearu noar's
brother I do have one older brother and
he does he he is fairly prominent he's a
he works at JP Morgan Chase um and he
does have a LinkedIn profile and all
this other stuff he's I think a VP and
fixed income if I'm not mistaken so um
that's a pretty straightforward answer
uh as far as who my brother is is hearu
nakura Japanese answer obviously is yes
I am 50% Japanese uh my biological
father 100% Japanese and my mother is
Caucasian white uh primarily a mix of
Scandinavian uh if we're being really
technical but I'm 50% Japanese is hearu
retired another good good question
evidently people have been watching a
lot of my streams and listening to these
5-second clips a lot as opposed to uh
paying attention to everything that I've
said uh the answer of course is no I'm
not retired from competitive chess I
still do play a lot of competitions but
I do consider myself more of a streamer
and a content creator first next up we
have wow this is long is hearu nakura
what is this retire related to ah
related to shinuki noar now this of
course is a a pretty standard one a lot
of people see my last name uh the last
name nakur is a very common Japanese
last name there are quite a few
prominent people who have that last name
um chuki I believe was the European foot
or not European sorry played in Europe
but the footballer um from Japan um
there's also there's also a ww I think
shinuki shinuki I think is the
footballer I think there's another one
who's also the wrestler in WWE if I'm
not mistaken but I'm not related to
either of them it's just that nakur is a
very common Japanese last name is hearu
Noor in TSM now anybody who doesn't
follow the world of Esports or streaming
specifically would have no idea what
that means cuz of course when I see
something like TSM and this is actually
a very old story but one of the first
stocks that I ever followed when I was
much younger was a TSM Corporation out
of Taiwan and I believe at the time or
even now I think the stock ticker is
still TSM even though everybody refers
to them as tsmc but this TSM is actually
referring to team solo mid the Esports
organization based in Los Angeles I was
a member um in 2020 and 2021 is he CaRu
nakur world champion so this of course a
generic question it depends what format
of Chess they're referring to if we're
talking about all forms of Chess I am
currently the Fisher random World chess
champion if you're referring to
traditional chess I am not the world
champion is see car
nakura the best chess player now a lot
of people like to think I have this
massive ego and I think I'm the best in
the world at chess um I am pretty good
but definitely not currently the best
chess player and historically uh nowh
near are the top uh but I would say I do
consider myself to be probably in the
top 10 to top 15 uh chess players of all
time which is still pretty good all
things considered thanks to the audience
of course for asking me these questions
and I hope that the answers are very
enjoyable for every body and they
learned something new
today